[MUSIC PLAYING]
JULIET EHIMUAN: Welcome
to Talks at Google.
I'm Juliet Ehimuan-Chiazor.
I'm the country manager
for Google Nigeria.
And I'm very
privileged and honored
to be speaking with our guest
for today, Professor Pat Utomi.
[APPLAUSE]
PAT UTOMI: Pleased to
be able to join you.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIET EHIMUAN: So
our theme for today
is leadership and
nation building.
These are topics
that Professor Utomi
has been known to really
share a lot of views about
and be actively involved in.
But I'll start with just
going through his profile.
This is probably the shortest
introduction you'll ever
get for Professor Utomi.
So Professor Utomi is a Fellow
of the Institute of Management
Consultants of Nigeria and
Founding Senior Faculty
of the Lagos Business School,
Pan-Atlantic University.
He was Director of the
Center for Applied Economics
at the Lagos Business School.
He has served in senior
positions in government
as an advisor to the
president of Nigeria,
the private sector
as Chief Operating
Officer for Volkswagen of
Nigeria, and in academia.
He is the author of several
management and public policy
books, including
the award-winning
"Managing Uncertainty,
Competition and Strategy
in Emerging Economies" in 1998,
and the 2006 book "Why Nations
Are Poor."
He has been a
scholar in residence
at the Harvard Business
School and the American
University in Washington DC.
As leader of civil
society, he is the founder
of the Center for Values in
Leadership, the Widow Support
Centre, and the Concerned
Professionals, which
was bulwark against
military operation
among numerous other social
enterprise initiatives,
and honored by so many
professional bodies
for the collection of
more than 700 plaques
that mark a life of service.
[APPLAUSE]
PAT UTOMI: I'll tell you,
we're over 1,000 now.
JULIET EHIMUAN: Over 1,000 now.
Professor Utomi, thank
you for being here.
PAT UTOMI: Thank
you for having me.
JULIET EHIMUAN: I said this was
the short version, didn't I?
PAT UTOMI: Actually, I have
a much, much shorter version.
When I introduce myself,
I say I'm a teacher.
JULIET EHIMUAN: At 60, which is
the oldest person in the room
right now, what do you
know for sure about life?
PAT UTOMI: Well, I
know for sure that I
don't know much about life.
You know, every day you
learn something new.
The way things were
yesterday seemed right.
They are wrong today.
So life is pay as you go, learn
as you go, adapt as you go.
But what's important
about life is
that you should be driven by
some very basic principles that
really never change, no matter
how the world around you
changes.
When I was at university,
I ran into something
that was chasing me from
when I was seven years old.
It's called a library.
And instead of going
to flying school,
I went to graduate school.
As a very young person,
I was significantly
shaped by a group of
American Catholic priests
in a very rural part
of Nigeria, a place
called Gusau in
today's Zamfara state.
And John F. Kennedy
was President
of the United States of
America, first Catholic
to be elected president.
And so I was the guinea pig.
Everything Kennedy
said, I was made
to read by this Catholic priest.
And at seven, I began
to love to read.
I read quite a bit
that, and literally I
read books [INAUDIBLE] were not
even looking at at that time.
And out of a sense of duty, I
was available most of the time.
And since there was
nothing else to do,
I began to read all the books
that were in the library.
So that's how I changed
my mind from flying school
and decided to correct--
I don't want to tell you
how I chose the subject
I studied at University
of Nigeria, but I should say.
I just closed my eyes
and put down the pencil.
I said, whatever I touch
is-- I'm just going
to spend a year or two there.
So it was for play.
And so what interests I had, I
had to pursue in grad school.
And that's how I ended up with
titles, number of degrees.
JULIET EHIMUAN: Interesting.
PAT UTOMI: Nothing--
JULIET EHIMUAN: So you
said you put a pencil?
PAT UTOMI: I just put
a pencil and said,
whatever this is, that's
what I'll fill in this form.
JULIET EHIMUAN: And it
really worked out OK.
PAT UTOMI: It did.
It did work out OK.
JULIET EHIMUAN: Fantastic.
And in all of this, why did
you decide to go into politics?
PAT UTOMI: Because
one basic thing
has driven most
of my adult life--
how can I make the world
around me better than I met it?
How can to make it
better, different?
And I saw different ways of
affecting the world around me,
and that led me to the
various things that I did.
At a point in time, there
was an overwhelming sense
that you make the most
difference in public life.
I have a fairly
different understanding
of things right now.
Sad to say, but I think that
in some developing countries--
Nigeria is a classic example--
the nature of the triumph
of politics makes political
life actually more detrimental
to progress than anything else.
I believe that the
government of Nigeria
does more to prevent progress
than to make it happen,
even if the goal is to
make progress happen.
But the level of goal
displacement in public life
is so massive that in
the end, government
assaults property
rights significantly,
because of the
interests of those who
have gone into those positions.
Government is
unable to quickly--
I just came back from
a tour of Australia,
as a guest of the
government of Australia.
And part of what I was
suggesting to those that I met,
including MPs,
government ministers,
you know, you could make a
greater difference by engaging
the private sector, engaging
social enterprise, in a country
like Nigeria, than engaging
the government of Nigeria.
It's a sad conclusion
to come to,
but that is unfortunately
the nature of the beast.
But we can't stop trying.
Obviously, you can make
a significant difference
if you get the right kinds
of values, the right kinds
of people, in public life.
But for now, the
government is significantly
a source of holding back
progress rather than making
progress happen.
JULIET EHIMUAN: And you went
for presidency in 2007 and 2011.
What do you think it would take
for someone with your profile
to be elected
president in Nigeria?
PAT UTOMI: An accident,
maybe many accidents.
With the power of the internet
and all of that-- I mean,
the way the Obamas of this
world emerged from what
in that political system would
have been thought impossible
a few short years before that
can also affect change here.
JULIET EHIMUAN: I'm
talking about that change.
So we hear an increasing
number of young people wanting
to get involved.
And we hear-- there are
two philosophies, actually,
that we've heard about
in the political space.
One is that power is
not given, it's taken.
Another is that power is
not a la carte, right?
How can young people
get a seat at the table
when you have such ideologies
around-- you have to grab 100%,
or it has to be
bestowed upon you.
PAT UTOMI: I think that
organizing-- politics has
always been about organization.
If young people organize,
you can get rid of all those
in power as they want.
Because we've got a youth bulge.
The majority of the
population is young.
If they realize that their
future is being really put
at risk by the kinds of
people who are in power,
and they realize
it starkly enough,
they can organize in a
way that can help them get
rid of those kinds of people.
We're talking about power,
not being served a la carte
or being taken.
Many years ago, I
held-- I came out
of an elevator at the Hilton
in Nigeria, comes out of Abjua.
And a very powerful
politician, [INAUDIBLE],
who was finance minister, I
think, at the time, sees me.
And he says, oh, Pat, you have
been complaining about things.
Nobody gives you power.
You have to take it.
Force us out.
And I thought, OK.
He's got a point.
And I've been trying very hard
to force them out since then.
JULIET EHIMUAN: So looking at
the world context of Nigeria,
we're talking leadership
and nation building.
And a lot of us
see the greatness
in our country, Nigeria.
It's the country with the
seventh largest population
in the world.
It's the largest
economy in Africa.
We've got entrepreneurial,
resilient, and very
talented people.
A high percentage of
young people, as well,
and all of that energy.
You have great weather,
fertile soil, and a [INAUDIBLE]
of natural resources.
But there are some harsh
realities, as well.
I mean, if you just
look out the window
at the NNPC filling station,
there are long queues,
fuel scarcity.
And you also
mentioned in your book
that our politic figures went
from 35% to 45% in 10 years,
right?
How would you assess where
we are today as a nation
relative to the promise of
Nigeria at independence?
PAT UTOMI: The
best way to compare
is to look at countries
that were peers.
As an old Nigerian politician of
great glamour, the [INAUDIBLE].
He's called [INAUDIBLE].
Any time I run into him,
he goes back to the fact
that in the '50s,
the countries that
were expected to change
the face of the world
coming out of the
developing or imagined
countries were India,
Brazil, Nigeria.
People didn't talk much about
the South Koreas of this world
back in those days.
Probably talk of the Malaysias.
And those ones emerged as
the frontiers countries
of a world in which
underdeveloped countries were
emerging fairly quickly.
Why did Nigeria, which held
so much promise in the '50s,
fall behind?
A number of factors.
One is what I call the
unfortunate alchemy of soldiers
and oil-- soldiers centralizing
authority, and oil making them
not need the tax
that people pay,
and therefore not bothering
to be held accountable.
This has worked against
Nigeria in so many ways,
because of the policy
choices that we've made
and are still making.
I mean, if you take two or three
of the major crises of now--
Veracruz.
That is as basic as common
sense can take anybody.
And I'm willing to put a bet
down that if Nigeria announced
today that anybody
who can refine
petrol-- petroleum products.
Anybody who wants to sell
[INAUDIBLE] from anywhere
in the world, as long as
they have certain standards,
is free to come into Nigeria
and sell for whatever price.
Prices will be lower than
the government official price
within the next year or so.
But it will not be done, because
people are extracting rent
from the process.
This person in power.
His people have finished
extracting rent.
The other person comes.
And it's always done in
the name of protecting
the government, who is
the victim, continuously,
of these dirigiste traditions.
We did it with
telecommunications.
I have a story-- it's
slightly long, but a story
on telecommunications.
In 1996, you know, I spent
a year on sabbatical leave
in the Boston area, at
Harvard Business School,
to write a book titled
"Managing Uncertainty"--
competition and strategy
in emerging economies.
Rented a small house on a street
called Elm Street in Cambridge.
And I wanted to get a phone.
And I thought, oh
dear, how do I do that?
I need to get to the
telephone company.
I went to the street
corner telephone booth,
called the phone
company, and said,
I need to have your
address so that I can
come in and get a telephone.
They said, but you don't need
to come in to get a telephone.
I said, oh, why not?
You just give us your details,
give us your last telephone
number, and if it's OK,
if it checks out OK,
by tomorrow morning, if you
pick up the phone in the house,
you will get a dial tone, and
I will give you your number.
Back in those days,
Nigeria had spent billions
of dollars trying to provide
telephones to its people,
and less than 280,000
telephone lines
were working in the entire
country of more than 100
million people.
And I thought, OK, those
guys-- I chose a long distance
provider.
The following morning,
I pick up the phone,
there's a dial tone all
right, and I begin to call.
You know somebody who has been
denied access, every night,
I've been at the phone, I
said you cannot believe this.
Are the kids ready?
Have they gone to school?
Blah, blah, blah.
So end of the first
month, I had a big bill.
Several months,
I had a big bill.
Of course, I paid my
bills as they came.
And then one day,
the phone is ringing.
I thought, oh, what's
happening in Lagos?
I grabbed the phone.
This is Sprint, the
long distance provider.
I say, yeah?
Any problem?
They say, yeah, we
noticed you've been
making lots of phone calls.
I said, yes.
Is there any problem with that?
I thought they think this
Nigerian [INAUDIBLE].
He's calling Nigeria all
the time or something.
They say, no, no, not at all.
Because you're such
a good customer,
we want to reduce
your rate to half.
I said, really?
Yes, in fact, the first two
months bills that you've paid,
we're going to give it
to you as a welcome gift.
So we'll deduct
them from future.
And I said, come, come, come.
This is September.
Christmas doesn't
come till December.
Tell me what the trick is here?
JULIET EHIMUAN:
What's the catch?
PAT UTOMI: Yeah.
When I dropped the phone, I said
to myself, dummy, dummy, dummy,
three times.
You came here to write a book
on competition and strategy,
and you see it, and
you can't recognize it.
And somebody is going to
get a hold of the fact
that some fellow is
making so many phone calls
and call me and offer
me a better rate.
And that's why the company
I was using moved first.
That's what's going to
happen to this country,
if we-- and we did eventually
with telecoms through the GSM
process.
Now from 280,000
working phone lines.
127 million.
So it's not rocket science.
Something with power.
You know, somebody was joking
with the minister from Nigeria.
I didn't know it was a
minister-- a West African
on a flight from Accra.
And says to this
minister, at the time,
a friend of mine [INAUDIBLE].
He says, this problem that you
have with electricity, tell me,
is that you who don't know
where to sell these things?
I can introduce you to GE if
you don't know where to these
sell these turbines.
Power will solve the problem
was solved 100 years ago.
The reason we've spent billions
of dollars and don't have power
is simply because we are playing
games with extracting rent
from the system.
As simple as that.
And we can fix these
things very easily
if we have people who
have the right mindset
and have real commitment
to the country.
JULIET EHIMUAN: So you
paint-- and I really
want to touch on that in
terms of the way forward.
You paint a very
comprehensive picture
in your book about
the people tell
things that have happened
since independence to get us
where we are.
From things like having
30 years of military rule,
and the impact on federalism,
undermining of institutions,
institutionalized corruption,
not effectively managing
volatility in the upstream and
downstream sectors of the oil
industry, not
diversifying our economy,
a decline in agriculture
and things like that.
And we will be able to
go into those in detail,
but they're covered in a lot
of great detail in the book.
Thinking about the way
forward and solutions,
you proposed a growth drivers
framework in your book
that had six things--
leadership, culture,
institutions, policy
choice, entrepreneurship
and human capital.
See, I was paying attention!
PAT UTOMI: Ah, absolutely.
It's amazing.
Even I don't
remember all of them.
JULIET EHIMUAN: So if we
start with leadership,
you've-- this is a big
area of focus for you.
And I believe you've
said on occasions
that part of our problem
through the years
has been a crisis in leadership.
What type of leadership,
in your opinion,
is required to take
Nigeria forward?
PAT UTOMI: Well, leadership
really is leadership,
but the leadership styles
and approaches to leadership.
Leadership simply is about
applying the self in a way
that goal direction, behavior,
through influencing others,
is smoothing by the fact
that you have knowledge,
you have a sense of
service towards people,
you have a value frame that
allow the people to see
a shared motive in solutions
to certain kinds of problems
that face them.
Some cultures make
the concepts--
the idea of the leader as a
shepherd-- more attractive.
You know, if you look
at bible, for example,
leadership emerges in the Bible.
Look at the shepherd, the
steward, and the servant.
The servant relation model
being essentially the one
that Jesus offered.
I advocate a model that I
call the solicitor leader.
And, in many ways, Mahatma
Gandhi, Nelson Mandela,
are closer to that
model-- people
who, by the sheer force of their
conviction, and the fact that,
like solicitors, they
engage the issues.
And so you have to know a great
deal to be a solicitor leader.
People will buy into
[INAUDIBLE] they have vision.
And therefore, there
is a lower cost
in mobilizing people
towards achieving
those broad objectives
that are set.
I think that, where you have
a significantly literate
population, perhaps
the shepherd leader
model can be very attractive.
We have a great number of
educated, younger people.
The solicitor leader model
is probably more attractive.
But sometimes, you get
a blend of these models.
And I think that,
really, we need,
in many cases,
solicitor leaders,
in some cases, some shepherds.
Unfortunately,
there is a tendency
to have this Messiah desire.
You know?
We're looking for a messiah.
This man will come and save us.
And it never quite happens like
that, for a variety of reasons.
The U.S. president,
Barack Obama,
on his first visit to
Africa, in his first speech
in Accra in Ghana, made
a very profound point,
which unfortunately for me had
been speaking to for years.
But nobody listened to me
until he said the same things.
You know?
What Africa needs-- strong
institutions, not strong men.
We are always looking for
strong man who will be messiahs.
And the problem with messiahs
is that those who succeed them
always want to undo
what they have done,
because the legitimacy
of the new guy
will not be achieved if that
other person's legacy holds.
So we get into these
recursive modes.
The Nigerian economy
has been described
as a recursive economy.
Two steps forwards,
four steps backwards,
essentially because of
this strong man role.
Because when a particular
governor comes,
and he backs on
all these projects,
his successor is sure to
abandon those projects
and start new projects.
You don't really
build like that.
JULIET EHIMUAN: Yeah.
PAT UTOMI: You know?
JULIET EHIMUAN: I agree
with you about the solicitor
model versus the messiah.
Because if you think about
it, responsibility should
exist at every level, right?
But it also raises the
question, from a very practical
perspective, how
do we go from-- say
there's a leader with the
best intentions, right?
There is still a need
to create that rallying
to a common vision, and also
influencing at every level,
right?
So how would we go from the
understanding of the issues,
et cetera, to actual, practical,
transformative action?
You know, I am a great admirer
of the Canadian writer Robin
Sharma, who writes about
the leader who had no title.
If we are all
educated to realizing
that we are all
leaders, and that we all
have a responsibility for
the change that we seek,
somebody being able to
effectively articulate it
helps us to patterns of
socialization, agencies
of socialization--
whether it's the church,
whether it's the school
system-- into a people who
start by buying into a
certain vision of the world.
And I call this the
pedagogy of the determined.
And not to give myself too
much credit for anything
here-- because I took it away
from a Brazilian educator
in the '60s and '70s
called Paulo Freire.
Paulo Freire was famous
for a book on education
that was titled "The
Pedagogy of the Oppressed."
And "The Pedagogy
of the Oppressed"
essentially looked
at the mindset
of oppressed people,
colonized people, and the kind
of education that they
get, like a piggy bank,
that enables them just make
itsy bitty little progress
within the context of the
enslavement of the world.
But if people were
trained to begin,
first of all, by developing
a certain vision of society,
and then all the
knowledge they seek
is to move them
towards that vision.
Paulo Freire was a Marxist.
I have never been
a Marxist, so I
had a basic problem with the
heavy ideological content
from the beginning.
So I took an
entrepreneurship approach
to the same idea of the
pedagogy of the oppressed
and say that people
need to begin
with a vision of
the world they want
to see and
entrepreneurially craft
what it is, can move their
world towards that location.
And this is the-- and
this kind of platform
is easy for a leader to mobilize
these other leaders to channel
society's energies
towards a certain goal.
And in some ways, you look at
what happened in South Korea,
you will see that happen.
There's a South
Korean-born economist
at Oxford called
Ha-Joon Chang, who's
written a very interesting
book titled "Bad Samaritans."
And it essentially looks
at the developmental states
and tells the story of how
South Korea got to where it is.
And I believe that we
need a developmental state
orientation.
But you need a
different set of leaders
from the kind of people
who we find in our country,
with massive levels of goal
displacement, where [INAUDIBLE]
is so important.
Whereas true leaders are
self-sacrificing people.
Leadership behavior is
others centered behavior.
If you look in the mirror, and
what you see most of the time
is me, myself, and I,
you're not a leader.
You need to, as you
look in the mirror, ask
how can this person touch other
lives and make a difference?
If you think that way,
there's a pretty decent chance
that you will make a leader.
So I think it's important
to bear these things in mind
in how we challenge ourselves
to how to move to where--
And young people are easy to
connect to this kind of thing.
And that's why
the future belongs
to how we connect
to a generation that
is-- in most of
the things they do,
they look for an aspirational
track that they can hook onto.
We have leaders that
connect properly into that,
it can drive a
generation towards
a different destination.
JULIET EHIMUAN: I think
that's very powerful.
If you look in the mirror,
and all you see is me, myself,
and I, then you're not a leader.
I think that's very powerful.
OK.
So we're still on the
subject of leadership, Prof.
And I'd like to bring this to
a very personal level, now.
You've had-- you've
been involved
in leadership positions in
business and government.
How would you critique yourself
and your role in these sectors,
and what, in your opinion,
could have gone better?
PAT UTOMI: You know, one
of the questions that you
get asked every
time by reporters
is, would you do
anything differently?
90% of the time, I hear
people say, no, you know,
I would never do
anything differently.
I would do everything
differently.
Because every new day,
I find a different way
of doing something better than
the way I did it yesterday.
But in the various roles that
I have played, some things have
come through that I could have
done in a way that, you know,
if I had a chance to do it
over-- part of the challenge is
in industry, of course, I
was a peculiar kind of player
when I was in industry.
When I got to work for
Volkswagen in Nigeria,
first day, I said
if I had my way,
I would scrap the business.
And everybody went,
is this guy crazy?
They just hired this guy, and
he says if he has his way,
he would scrap the plant.
It wasn't because I
thought we shouldn't
have business in that area.
It was because I thought that
was not the most effective way
to play.
Motor assembly business, where
we're not so competitive,
isn't where we
should be playing.
We should probably look at where
we have comparative advantage.
[INAUDIBLE]
endowments that enable
us to build global value chains
that we can significantly
dominate.
I recall in those early days,
when I was saying these things,
and I was hammered by
the media all around,
a professor from
Oxford, [INAUDIBLE],
came to interview me.
He was curious.
And I said, look,
if I had my way,
I would get the
government of Nigeria
to sign agreements
with Volkswagen,
[INAUDIBLE], Peugeot,
and all the fellows
we were producing, or trying
to do security operations here.
Take a component that is based
on some factor which we're
dominantly [INAUDIBLE]
rubber and become suppliers
into the global supply chains of
those companies for one or two
components alone, first of all,
would create many more jobs
in Nigeria.
We would [INAUDIBLE].
In fact, at a point in
time, I was cocky enough
to suggest that we'd earn more
from the rubber value chain
if we added value, that
we're earning from crude oil.
And I made a presentation at the
first Nigeria Economic Summit
on that in 1980-- well,
[INAUDIBLE] first year
was 1993.
That was the first
economic summit.
And I should have been
more aggressive in that.
I expressed it,
and I kept saying,
these guys-- at a point, I
said, OK, I've had enough.
I'm walking away from this.
But if I had fought
must strongly--
and managers are not supposed
to be head in this environment,
on these kind of issues that
are really big policy issues.
Of course, I broke that
rule, but I should have even
broken it more.
Because if I manage to educate
enough people to understand
the point I was
making, then Nigeria
would not be as far back as
it is in manufacturing today.
A good example is that Paul
Collier, fast forward 25 years
after, gets asked
by UNIDO to study
China's rapid advance
in manufacturing
and what Africa
could learn from it.
And when Paul Collier was
done and shared his study,
one of the things that came
out was that China basically
did what [INAUDIBLE]
told me was suggesting
Nigeria do 25 years earlier.
And Collier gives
one example of it.
As a local government in China,
and manufactures nearly 75%
of all the buttons
worn on the planet.
That was the whole
idea, that if Nigeria
became the dominant supplier
of one or two rubber
components in the motor car
to production worldwide,
Nigeria would be in
a different sphere.
Manufacturing would have
risen dramatically in Nigeria.
So in many ways, I
hold myself personally
responsible for Nigeria's
failure by not fighting harder.
To say this is the way to go.
Let all these people
control ideas.
You know?
Just wear me down,
and I walked away.
That was a big error.
Almost the same reason why,
but in the politics, actually--
because I was part of this
group called "The Concerned
Professionals."
And we're professionals
who fought in the military.
Who are against the annulment of
the fair elections of the 12th
of June in 1993, right?
And in the end, when
the military abandoned--
were running away after all
that struggle-- we thought,
we are professionals.
We should just go
back to our business
and let politicians take over.
So big mistake.
What happened was that
the original politicians--
the people who followed
[INAUDIBLE], who
followed Okpara,
Azikiwe, [INAUDIBLE],
were not sure that
these soldiers really
meant to go away.
So they held back.
And the bad men of the
soldiers, they are contractors,
became the new politicians.
Nigeria has paid a
very dear price for it.
The deep corruption in our
system came from the culture
that it brought to politics.
And when I realized what was
going on, it was already late.
Because they came at
a time of big boom.
Oil prices have
gone to over $100.
It captured the state, extracted
the resources of the state,
[INAUDIBLE], and used
it to erect a barrier
into public life.
Nigerian politics
became about money,
which they have stolen
from the Nigerian state,
and more people could not
get into political life.
So in 2005 or so, a
group of us who said,
no, we shouldn't go into
politics met and we said,
we made a mistake.
Let's admit it to ourselves.
That's how they
said to me, wrong.
At least just use that
to begin to define
where Nigeria should be going.
JULIET EHIMUAN: Thank
you for sharing those.
And coming back to
the growth rivals,
entrepreneurship is
another one you talk about.
And I personally believe that
home-grown entrepreneurship
is very key to economic
transformation.
What excites you about
the entrepreneurship
space in Nigeria right now?
We've seen growth in the
entertainment industry,
for example, particularly the
music and Nollywood industries.
We've seen virility in the
technology entrepreneurship
space.
We are very fast becoming
a helpful innovation.
It's been dubbed the
Silicon Valley of Nigeria.
We've seen a growth
in e-commerce.
We're attracting foreign
direct investment, and so on.
What's your take on this space?
And you've been very
involved-- you've
been quite the entrepreneur
as well, yourself.
PAT UTOMI: Well,
I guess I was so
persuaded that that
was the way to go, that
in the early days of Lagos
Business School, my colleagues
and I had long battles over
the place of entrepreneurship
in our programs.
The argument, which
was reasonable,
was that we were a general
management institution,
we should focus on
general management.
I argued that if
Nigeria did not create
an entrepreneurial culture--
[INAUDIBLE] enterprise class--
we would not be what our
promise is supposed to be.
This went on until 1996.
I think it was March, 1996.
A friend of mine, an African
American investment banker,
Malcolm Pryor, who
was a Wharton alum
and was on the board of
Wharton, I was visiting with him
in Philadelphia.
And I indicated an interest in
meeting the dean at Wharton.
And he set it up, and we both
went to visit with the dean.
And I talked about
entrepreneurship.
In the course, he
said, oh, we have
a great center, the [INAUDIBLE]
Center of Entrepreneurship.
And the guy who runs
it is an African,
is an African
fellow at the time.
And we went to visit.
And I saw cubicles
where they were
providing clinics for local
Philadelphia businessmen.
It was an opportunity
for them to give back
to the community much
more than anything else.
When I came back to Lagos, I--
[INAUDIBLE] on my colleagues
that they gave up.
So I designed and taught the
first entrepreneurship class
at the Lagos Business School.
And that's how it all started.
That seed eventually became
what is called EDC today,
Enterprise Development Center
at the Lagos Business School.
And in many ways,
idea for trying
to stimulate entrepreneurship,
somehow when--
again, I went to a West African
Enterprise Network meeting
in 1993, I think it was, or so.
And people from small
West African countries
had email addresses.
We didn't have one in
Nigeria, because we were not
on the internet.
And I came in and challenged
the class that I was teaching.
Somebody from their class came
to me afterwards and said,
you know, we could work
on something together.
That's how Linkserve was born.
And that's how Nigeria got
on the internet, Nigeria's
first ISP.
So that developed.
Again, they're
sort of other ones.
But the one that I like-- you
know, I romanticize really
in my conversations--
is in Hollywood.
I used to argue
that Nigeria would
be more competitive selling its
culture than selling crude oil.
There is so much
in Nigerian culture
that could be packaged properly
and sold around the world.
There was a romantic thing,
literally, to talk about.
But in Indian fashion, nobody
paid any attention to it.
When I saw a group of
out of work men and women
pick up on old cameras and
begin to make these videos,
I got excited.
And I began to
offer-- because I knew
they couldn't afford
it-- I began to offer
free seminars for them.
On Saturdays, I'll come in and
do a workshop free of charge.
So this is a business.
You've got to operate
yourself like a business.
So go back 20 years,
and you see Nigeria
trying to rebuild its economy
and pointing to Nollywood.
And I said, look
at these people who
all laughed at me 20 years ago.
But it makes one feel
good [INAUDIBLE] part
of the process like that.
JULIET EHIMUAN: Fantastic.
PAT UTOMI: The future
going forward I
think is going to depend
very much-- I say this
with respect for everybody.
I think the repats, the young
Nigerian men and women educated
abroad who are coming home
will be the ultimate stimulants
of the new economy.
Because of the experience, the
exposure, where they've been.
When they come back, I think
that entrepreneurial zest
will drive it.
JULIET EHIMUAN: And
I agree with you
that industries like our
music industry and Nollywood
are, in many ways, exporting
aspects of Nigerian culture.
And even financially,
putting that online,
talking into the export market.
PAT UTOMI: Yeah.
If I may just-- it's
not just that, you know,
as entrepreneurs they will
create wealth and all of that.
But they are also agents of
soft power for a country.
A couple of years ago,
some friends of mine,
Nigerian doctors
in California who
travel out every year
to some African country,
on some goodwill initiative to
offer free medical services,
were in Congo, Democratic
Republic of Congo.
And it was election time,
and all the [INAUDIBLE]
around the place was
Camilla [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE] called
me and said, you're
not going to believe this.
I mean, [INAUDIBLE].
And all the billboards,
Camilla [INAUDIBLE].
So I asked somebody, there's
a Nigerian word like that.
Is any language group here
that speaks that kind of?
[INAUDIBLE] Nollywood.
The big man in town
is [INAUDIBLE],
so Camilla's campaign
was Camilla [INAUDIBLE].
That meant it was a [INAUDIBLE].
JULIET EHIMUAN: I'll just tough
on two other growth drivers,
and then we can take
questions from the audience.
So still on all of the
benefits of entrepreneurship
[INAUDIBLE], which is a huge
challenge in Nigeria today?
We know that
unemployment figures
are in the double digits.
From your perspective, and
based on your experience,
how do you think we can
create jobs at scale?
PAT UTOMI: Again, the kind
of areas of new enterprise
that will determine what
kinds of jobs we create.
Nigeria is in a position
to tap into the [INAUDIBLE]
to create a
demographic dividend.
What unfortunately
has happened to us
is that we've had a
jobless growth economy.
And this is for a
variety of reasons.
A lot of the growth has taken
place driven sometimes by oil,
and has gone to a
few people in what
is a significantly
divergent Gini
measure, a Gini index,
a coefficient of income
distribution.
A few people capture
most of the wealth.
And because they're really
not truly entrepreneurs,
the money just
leaves the country.
They're essentially extracting
rent from the system.
But if they were
entrepreneurs that
were trying to create
additional wealth,
we would make a
lot more progress.
So if we encourage
an enterprise class
that [INAUDIBLE] has done, in a
number of jobs he has created.
But you can do that
even in tech economy.
You can do that in other areas.
If it brought the
number of people
were involved in enterprises
that actually create
wealth, not extract rent.
So I think that we need to
provide certain incentives
for certain kinds of businesses
that have [INAUDIBLE] again
factor endowments in which we
can create value chains that
are global.
And each part of
this country has
a certain set of endowments.
Of course, you can
compete globally.
Look at Central Nigeria.
Sesame seeds grow in
the wild, literally.
Imagine if you organized
people, and they have
plantations of sesame seeds.
And they process,
and they supply
to every McDonald's
hamburger store in Europe
from out of-- and millions
and millions of dollars,
and they would create
hundreds of thousands
of jobs, just on
Sesame seeds alone.
You go to various areas.
Nigeria has this long coast
line of oil and gas assets.
If you just said
to everybody who
wanted to sell they had a
couple value chain products can
establish, export, do
whatever from there
and create millions of jobs only
had to cover the value chain.
So it has to be focused.
It has to be targeted.
And there have to be sets
of incentives that encourage
those kinds of
investments, and government
has to get out of the way.
The more you can get government
out of the way, the more likely
it is that you can create
these opportunities.
JULIET EHIMUAN: So I'm
going to pause at this point
and see the questions
from the audience.
I know a number of questions
were submitted online.
Just see if anyone
in the room wants
to raise a question before we
go into what we have online.
PAT UTOMI: "Patito's Gang,"
you know, talking legacy,
maybe that will
ultimately be my legacy.
Because I get
stopped at airports
as far away as Los Angeles, LAX.
And somebody has run up to me
and say, excuse me, excuse me,
are you-- and then I hear
this "Patito's Gang" story.
You know, Nigerians who now live
around the world who say they
grew up on "Patito's Gang."
I feel good about that.
It was just about creating
a marketplace of ideas.
Unless a nation can get good
quality conversation going,
it will not create the
ideas that it requires
to get-- that are acceptable.
Everybody owns the move forward.
And people don't know
the kind of sacrifice
I made to put that program up.
When I produced--
when we started,
I wanted for it to be the
best possible quality.
In fact, the first director was
American who lived in Nigeria.
And we had, in the
then director general,
or immediate past
director general
of NTA engineer
[INAUDIBLE] man who
told me, after the first two
episodes, and said to me,
it's impossible to
sustain that quality.
Because we had roof shots.
We had all kinds of--
but wanted to do it well.
And after three
episodes, I get a call
from a friend of mine,
managing director of one
of the most successful
commercial banks
in the country.
And he says to me, oh, Pat,
what a fantastic-- he goes on
and on and on.
When he finished, I said
to him, you know what?
I'm glad you love it, because
we need commercial support
for that thing to be air.
He said, oh, Pat, but you guys
speak the truth, you know.
And truth is not--
JULIET EHIMUAN: Lucrative.
PAT UTOMI: You know, I
wouldn't want somebody
to think that I'm putting
you guys up to that speaking
of the truth, you know?
But the day you will
do sports, let me know.
We'll pay twice as much.
But that was part
of the problem.
Actually, the reason
I could keep that
show running for
as long as I did--
it was more than 10 years.
It did come back after
a one-year break.
It was on until last year,
second quarter of last year,
but when it first started,
it was on the NTA network.
It was on channels.
It was literally on
every television at work.
And not only did we spend a
lot of money to produce it,
we paid those television
stations to air it.
That's the kind of
business model we have.
Instead of them to pay you
for content, you paid to air.
And the way that [INAUDIBLE]
television going was we
had-- the computer was set off.
Had a big institutional
advertising contract
with a big multinational, and
something completely different
that was called
leadership reflections.
But they paid us so well
that the entire gain
from that, and more,
we had to fight
for-- went into that program--
was one particular year,
it cost me literally
100 million naira
to keep "Patito's
Gang" on the air.
Advertising revenue,
Nigerian companies
were scared to advertise on
a program that spoke truth
to power.
So you see how challenging
it can be out there.
So after many years, I
have become literally
bankrupt from trying to do
service to the Nigerian people.
And I thought, I
better stop this.
And as soon as I stopped,
everybody started complaining.
So we had to try and get back.
But yes, I'd be pleased
to do another one.
JULIET EHIMUAN: And
probably-- because it
sounds like a great
output for the Center
for Values and Leadership.
And with the digital
world today, right?
Production cost had to
be so high, et cetera.
And there's more
room for sharing,
and for people to help
amplify that voice, et cetera.
So it's something that
could be working online.
PAT UTOMI: Yes, yeah.
JULIET EHIMUAN: Online.
PAT UTOMI: And about
being at the table,
I talked to that earlier.
You see, there's
more than enough
power in the hands of
young people today.
You're using social
media and all of that
to just educate each
other about the fact
that this is not going
to be accepted by us.
Because you have the majority!
60% of those who will
vote in the next election
will be under the age of 30.
Imagine if only 50% of
those decide that this
is the way we want to go.
They can't stop you from being
at the table if you organize,
about organization.
A book written in 1911, I
think, on the political parties,
and political parties
is about organization.
Organization is about
political police.
He who says organization
essentially says oligarchy.
The guy's name is
Robert Michaels.
Once political parties emerge,
they will be oligarchies.
A few people will control them.
But if young people use correct
technology to build a different
idea base, different ideology,
they can send the nation
travelling a different track.
PAT UTOMI: Now about the guy who
has all his money in dollars.
First of all, there are so
many foolish people in Nigeria,
because I consider
it foolishness.
You are developing
other economies
and starving your own country of
oxygen. And maybe I'm foolish,
but I don't have much-- I tell
people I don't have a room.
Most people have several houses.
I was in Nigeria.
I don't have a room
outside Nigeria.
Almost every investment,
just about-- not almost.
Every investment I
have is in Nigeria.
I probably can find 20,000
pounds or something that I
leave abroad just
in case I can't send
my childrens' [INAUDIBLE]
quickly enough from Nigerian
banks.
But I would never
probably have much more
than that outside Nigeria.
For people who are
not particular wise,
it might seem like something
prestigious, or something
that they play safe with.
But you know what happens?
Most of them, most of them
die and leave all that money.
Because there are usually
not man enough to even
tell their wives that
they have such money.
So it is not wisdom,
it's foolishness.
That is said very
often, but it's
one of those lies that the
system structures to, you know,
let people feed on.
First of all, the Senate is a
completely useless institution.
It has no power whatsoever,
affects nothing,
as far as I'm concerned.
Except the [INAUDIBLE].
If we need to
restructure government,
I would go to a unicameral
legislature that is very small.
[INAUDIBLE], who is
currently a minister,
after serving in the Senate,
when I was running in 2006,
said to me, you know, the
years I spent in the Senate
were the biggest
waste of my life.
They do very little
in terms of value add.
It's culture.
It's a culture of executive.
You have the strings.
Because all people
are looking for
is the purse who can
hold the purse strings.
Everybody comes
bowing before you.
And not knowing that you can use
the instruments to do greater
good, they focus
on the power side.
So I really don't believe
in the legislature thing.
It can be wonderful,
legislature.
But the way it's
structured today,
you contribute freely to it.
If we return to a elementary
British, Westminster type
system, then I would
value the legislature.
Right now, really the
only thing that matters
is the executive branch.
Judiciary can be very important.
They do certain things
to help the building
of the institutions.
But you know the track.
There is a different track.
The other part of
the question is
about what I think of the
way things are right now.
I think that what has affected
the way things are right now,
same reason why the [INAUDIBLE]
who ran-- how did we get here?
Again, history often does not
get written fairly or properly.
From my experience
in 2007, I was
convinced that if Nigeria did
not build a viable opposition,
Nigeria was not going
to get very far.
If power does not go
from one group in power
today to another-- their
position nobody feeds
the incumbent regime,
democracy will not
be different in this country.
And so my commitment
from the beginning
was in working with
an opposition group
to build a true opposition.
In post-colonial Africa,
there's a concept
of the corporatist state, where
the state tries to incorporate
a strong voice of opposition.
You get appointed a
minister by people
who don't like you so that
they can keep you quiet.
[INAUDIBLE] in Africa.
At some point in
time, [INAUDIBLE]
to become an
attorney general was
becoming president of the
Nigerian Bar Association.
Because the Bar Association
used to give a lot of trouble
to government.
[INAUDIBLE] becoming
Minister of Health
was President of the
Nigerian Medical Association.
As an example I like to
give-- [INAUDIBLE] to him--
a very strong leader of
the enemy [INAUDIBLE]
became minister of health,
and the government usually
used him to destroy the enemy.
And the day he was
dropped from the cabinet,
a person close to him
said he cried like a baby.
He had nowhere to go back
to, and nobody has ever
since heard of him.
So many times that
I've been asked
to cabinet positions, questions
that I've always asked
is, to do what?
If you want me in a team, I
want a certain critical mass
of people who
believe in something.
And you must believe
in a certain agenda
that we all agree to
before the journey starts.
So what you do see happening
is going on right now,
is that I think we have
a team that isn't even
[INAUDIBLE] the
person who's leading.
I think that most
ambassadors of the cabinet
will tell you that they don't
agree with the policies that
have left these petrol queues.
They will tell you
they don't agree
with the policies that
have created a mess
in the foreign exchange market.
They will tell you they don't
agree with the policies that
are affecting, very
sadly, [INAUDIBLE]
of educational system
and so on and so forth.
But everybody is
looking ineffectual,
because people haven't
developed the culture
of saying "I'm sorry, this is
not what we agreed, I quit."
But I think that
that is very useful,
to send a signal to
people who have authority.
JULIET EHIMUAN: Well,
thank you very much, Prof.
I know there are many questions.
I do apologize.
I also have a lot
of questions, but we
can't get to them, because Prof
has a lecture this afternoon.
So we have to wrap up.
But we can continue the
conversation online.
To wrap up, I'm just
going to ask, what's
the next chapter for you?
What do the next
60 years look like?
PAT UTOMI: Oh, this is going to
sound a little corny, because I
keep telling people--
young people,
and it's the truth--
from very early,
I had the good fortune of
re-instituting [INAUDIBLE]
very early in my life.
And so I had a vision statement.
I had personal missions.
I had all of those things.
But I tell you, it's important
to live it one day at a time.
However, I think that, as
I keep making this point,
that Nigeria has a major
public life challenge, that
is going to take
individual effort to move
Nigeria towards its destiny.
I'm looking to play
private roles that
can have transformative
impact in the economy.
I look at Nigeria
at a time when,
given its general endowments--
human, particularly--
and the possibilities in Africa
seen from the era of Afro
pessimism to one in which
significant progress is
expected, that private capital
can come into this country
from elsewhere, if we can
manage to do enough talking
to get government out of
the way and change not just
infrastructure.
Look, the Chinese
have significant money
that they have put aside to
do industrial parks in Africa,
with success in those.
There are infrastructure hubs
developing out of Australia,
and all of the private capital
and common infrastructure.
Nigeria has been talking
about a second major bridge
for forever.
Bangladesh, one of the poorest
countries in the world,
is building several bridges,
an underground tunnel,
the estuary.
We need thinking
people to engage
as private,
non-government actors
in the international economic
arena for our country.
And in some ways,
[INAUDIBLE] myself,
I'm an appointed
ambassador in that area.
And I hope that this will
make some contribution.
JULIET EHIMUAN: Right.
We could go on and on, but
we'll continue the conversation
online.
Thank you so much, Prof.
[APPLAUSE]